Mr Fisk
Welcome back everyone this will be my full marvel
hawkeye episode 6 finale video there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs i'll explain what's going on
with the characters where they're going to show up
next because most of these big characters like
the real big ones like kingpin will be coming back
also explain how this crosses over with the
events of spider-man no way home if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos i'll be doing episode videos
for the book of boba fett that's starting next
week too that'll be like our next big series
then i believe marvel's moon night episodes will
be like the next marvel disney plus series early
next year and then the she-hulk episodes but i'll
cover those in different videos when they drop
more trailers for them careful for spoilers from
hawkeye episode 6 if you have not seen it yet and
careful for spoilers for spider-man no way home if
you haven't seen the movie yet just because what
to talk about the crossover moments we'll just
start at the beginning and work our way through
shot by shot talking about moments and easter eggs
as we go along starting with the episode title
so this is christmas just a reference to that
ticking clock like the deadline that hawkeye set
for himself the promise he made to his family i'll
make it home by christmas which he did which was
the big theory like they wanted to have a happy
ending so it was going to be more optimistic than
say like the loki ending where he completely
fubar the multiverse with the help of sylvie
the actual crossover was spider-man no way home
happens at the end of the movie when spider-man
is seen swinging in his brand new costume right
through rockefeller center in the christmas tree
here in the ice rink where we saw them fight
in the hawkeye finale but the idea is that they
destroy the tree during the hawkeye finale and
it's closer to actual christmas day so i think
the idea is that spider-man is swinging here
through rockefeller center a couple days before
or just a little while before the events of the
hawkeye finale so like he isn't swinging through
while they're fighting but he's swinging around
new york city while the events of the hawkeye
series is happening i know there's a lot of big
questions about what happened with the way they
left the kingpin character what they did with
him in the episode don't worry i'll talk about
that in depth in the future of his character in
the mcu and we get to that part of the episode
but suffice to say he is not dead like that is
not the last time you'll see kingpin in the mcu
getting kingpin and daredevil in the mcu in the
same week how's that for a christmas present from
kevin feige but the actual episode starts with
kingpin himself showing up to a meeting with
kate's mother and it's basically the meeting that
yelena belova was telling kate bishop about and
sending her pictures and video from and during the
scene they basically explained what their history
was confirming a lot of our theories that we've
had since the first couple of episodes but one
of the big things they've done for the kingpin
in the mcu reintroducing him from the daredevil
netflix series is they've given him a different
version of the white suit that he wears in the
comics and they've given him the cane that he
uses in the comics he didn't use that during
the daredevil netflix series he doesn't actually
need it in the comics he just uses it as a weapon
but they confirmed that kate's father was
in serious debt with the kingpin that when
he died during the avengers battle of new york
during the events of the first avengers movie
his mother was left to repay the debt to kingpin
and she basically used bishop security to do that
doing him favors just doing whatever he asked of
her using all the technology that they used to
track people like they've already confirmed that
she was basically behind the tracksuits in the hit
on the auction during episode 1 so they do stuff
like that all over the city just things that you
would expect the mafia to do they don't completely
explain everything that happened to him after the
events of daredevil season 3 daredevil beat him
successfully got him arrested again and then
as far as we know he didn't get snapped because
he was around during the five-year time jump when
hawkeye was ronin to actually call out the hit
on ekko's father but they never really referenced
infinity war during daredevil season three so i
think the idea is that like a lot of criminals and
other villains in the mcu who didn't get snapped
they used the five-year time jump to grow their
power base le kingpin used the five-year time jump
to retake control of new york city for the most
part they set of the whole eleanor versus kingpin
arc during the episode it plays out pretty quickly
they confirmed the theory that she was actually
the person behind armand's murder not that she
necessarily did it herself like she wasn't the one
who actually stabbed him in the back literally but
she is the person responsible for it like kingpin
told her to get it done and she used the tracksuit
bros that's what the whole sloan company was about
that was just a shell company that she was using
to pay the tracksuit bros and make it seem legit
i'm sure matt murdock daredevil would love to get
his hands on some of that evidence that eleanor
bishop has but one of the things they're really
trying to do in this kingpin opening scene here is
to clearly set him up as the main villain of the
series like you kind of thought the eleanor bishop
was going to wind up being the main villain and
kingpin would kind of be like a side character no
no no they want you to think kingpin is the real
main villain then hawkeye basically gives kate
bishop everything that she's been wanting from him
for the past couple of episodes he calls her
his partner then they spend most of the episode
teaming up like having their own little team
hawkeye avengers assemble moments he also shows
her how to create trick arrows so i think the idea
is that the next time we see kate bishop come back
maybe she'll show up during ant-man 3. she'll have
a bunch of her own trick arrows that she's created
herself when they're doing the montage of them
creating all the trick arrows though there's a
bunch of big easter eggs here from the comics so
the guardian pepper spray is just a subtle easter
egg for the guardian marvel character he's from
the x-men comics but he was part of alpha flight
with wolverine and even though they're creating a
bunch of new trick arrows here they're also fixing
up and repairing a lot of the old trick arrows
too that you've seen before so there's about 20
different trick arrows here about half of them
are ones that he had before and half of them are
brand new ones like he whips out the pymtech arrow
again that he'd used before but this time they use
it for shrinking the tracksuit bros instead of
making something bigger they set up a couple of
jokes they pay off later like the arrow that's too
dangerous and then when she grabs the label maker
and actually labels it too dangerous and starts
labeling the other arrows that's a callback to the
earlier episode during the car chase when she was
grabbing all the wrong arrows yelling at hawkeye
because none of them were labeled so she didn't
know which one she was grabbing at any given time
some of the new ones that they confirm are the
airbag arrow the freeze arrow the flash bomb
arrow the icebreaker arrow then there's a couple
other ones from the comics we see hawkeye use like
the electro disrupter arrow and even though it is
kind of a bummer to see kingpin snap most of the
trick arrows like a bunch of twigs they wind up
paying off the trick arrow that's quote-unquote
too dangerous also by paying off the coin flip
trick when kate bishop flips the coin then sets
off the chain reaction to take kingpin down using
the too dangerous arrow they also remind you that
a lot of these trick arrows are based on stark
tech as iron man joked during avengers age of
ultron he literally makes all their cool toys
a lot of what hawkeye does creating his trick
arrows is improvisation like he has some of the
old favorites like trick arrows that he always
uses in his quiver but then sometimes based on the
situation he'll create something new like i said
though this is all just meant to be a tutorial
for kate bishop because she's slowly becoming the
next version of hawkeye so she has to learn how
to create her own trick arrows then they set up
the whole echo versus kingpin arc in the episode
sort of paying off the idea with her learning the
truth about what happened with her father kingpin
calling out the hit on her father confirming that
kingpin is the uncle character like we all knew it
a couple episodes ago but this just confirms that
and even though she lies to him like she's
kind of trying to feel him out asking for a
couple days off kingpin knows exactly what she's
doing like oh we gotta get rid of her now too
but despite all the backstabbing it does seem
like he genuinely cares about her it's just
that his business of controlling the city as the
kingpin controlling the mafia is more important to
him than she is kate bishop finally tells hawkeye
about the story of seeing him during the battle of
new york what it was like for her how it inspired
her to become a hero i believe there was a trailer
scene from a while ago where hawkeye jokes that
he actually broke a bunch of bones when he swung
in like yes it looked really cool because you were
little kids seeing me do this but in actuality i
broke most of my bones doing that but her whole
speech is about the idea that you don't need
superpowers to be a hero even though you just have
an arrow some string and a bow you're still a hero
to me there's some more cool training scenes with
hawkeye trying to mentor kate bishop like okay
size up all the threats and assets at the party
here and we learned that they have all the larpers
working on staff trying to help them case the
party they have a couple funny moments with jack
he actually has a pretty funny arc during this
episode and they confirm that he is like the himbo
of hawkeye he knew absolutely nothing about what
was going on like he was oblivious to everything
that kate's mother was doing this whole time that
he was in a relationship with her and they just
play it like he's enjoying himself like nobody's
business like he's just happy to be here like oh
i finally get to use my sword skills let's have
some fun and based on his ending in the episode
it seems like he's going to be joining the larpers
group there's this level of theatricality to his
character it seems like he would fit in with them
perfectly i loved everything about yelena belova's
arc during the episode and all of her scenes with
kate bishop but all the scenes she had with kate
bishop were amazing we need way more of their
characters teaming up together you also notice
that she enters the party wearing green and stark
contrast to all the other people that are wearing
black and red just sort of foreshadowing her fight
in front of the giant green christmas tree on the
ice with clint later in the episode and they have
all those funny scenes with kate bishop like they
both try to jump into the elevator pressing all
the buttons on the elevator to slow them down so
they have to stop at every floor it's an oldie
but a goodie and that funny reveal of her new
costume like did you do that on purpose this is
just a version of her comic book costume they do
the same thing for hawkeye later when he takes it
off like oh yeah you wore your new costume hawkeye
is wearing a version of his costume from the matt
fraction run which inspired the story of a lot of
the hawkeye series love the way that yelena yeets
out the window and almost takes out hawkeye using
the same trademark black widow move the tether
and the way that kate bishop has her own superhero
landing like she does her own superhero landing
with the pose just like natasha did and then
just like yelena belova did during the black widow
movie so kate bishop also a total poser just like
the others they pay off that joke with tomas from
earlier in the series the tracksuit bro thanking
kate bishop for the relationship advice she gave
him about the concert in most of the takedowns
that she has during this big final fight here
like sliding around the ice just meant to show
how she's grown over the series and learn from
hawkeye they set up the joke with the owl when
hawkeye gets thrown into the tree after they cut
his zipline but i do have some questions about the
owl that carried off that tracksuit bros little
miniaturized truck like is it going to eat them
like mice now did the pym particles wear off and
the tracksuit pros in the truck get bigger later
they don't get to use all the trick arrows here
but they do use some of the ones that they've used
before like kate bishop uses the acid arrow again
to basically cut the tree down or burn through
the tree trunk we get hawkeye versus yelena belova
round two after she tackles him on the ice but it
really isn't much of a fight like this is more of
a conversation that they have where he basically
explains what happened to natasha but it was
always going to have to end with a conversation
like this like okay this is what actually happened
on vermeer she wanted to sacrifice herself
it felt a little weird that it was the bird call
that actually turned her around on hawkeye like
wait a minute how did you know that they were just
trying to say that yelena belova didn't understand
how close hawkeye was to natasha like they were
like brother and sister but yelena belova didn't
really learn about hawkeye until later like
she knew about the avengers so the idea is
that the bird call was something that natasha and
yelena developed when they were children during
the black widow movie we saw that flashback and
only they knew about like it was a secret between
the two of them and that's why she did it at her
gravestone in the black widow post-credits scene
so when she heard clint use the secret call
that was just a way to say oh no natasha would
have told him all of her deepest secrets so that
means that they were super close she trusted him
she bails and runs off into the night obviously
this isn't the last time we're going to see her
there's still all the stuff going on with valve
that's unresolved with a thunderbolts team and
while they're resolving the hawkeye versus yelena
belova fight we get echo versus kazi and this all
kind of feels a little bit rushed like they tried
to imply there was some relationship between the
two of them a couple episodes ago but we haven't
spent a ton of time with the echo character so you
can kind of tell how they're trying to set her
up as an anti-hero on the series but it feels
like there just wasn't enough of her story also
in the same way that they just kind of introduced
kingpin in the last two episodes like oh hey
here's kingpin he's been doing a bunch of stuff
like wait a minute i have so many questions
about this now even though they play this like
echo kills qazi the actor who plays kazi said
that he would love to come back for the echo
spin-off series so because you don't actually see
his body put in the ground like he's not buried or
anything like that they could always say that he
survived but then they finally give us some actual
kingpin action scenes so when he rips the door off
eleanor's car and seems like he's gonna yoink her
right out of it it's meant to be a callback to
the daredevil netflix scene when he grabbed the
russian out of the car and beat him to death with
the door you embarrass me in front of vanessa
they have a couple jokes about how hard it is to
kill him when he soaks all the damage from kate's
arrows and just gets plowed through the department
store window like this is an fao schwartz that
he gets plaid into if it wasn't clear from the
daredevil netflix series in the comics kingpin
is huge like they kind of did him that way during
spider-man into the spider verse like he has a
tiny little head on this massive body that's what
he looks like in the comics in all this bulk that
you see here underneath his clothes that's not
fat he's pure muscle it only looks like fat
which is one of the ways why he winds up beating
so many people in one on one fights because they
underestimate his physical abilities like he
throws kate bishop around that fao schwartz like
she's a toy and then snaps her trick arrows like
they're a bunch of twigs but she is able to slow
him down a little bit with the coin flip trick
and the arrow that's too dangerous just paying
off those setups from earlier in the episode then
i was a little disappointed with the way they
resolved kate bishop in her mother's arc when she
winds up getting arrested like they're arresting
her for armond's murder she's going to be chilling
out in prison for a little while just like kingpin
got sent to prison during daredevil season 2.
maybe if they do hawkeye season 2 they'll bring
her mother's character back like i said i was a
little disappointed that there wasn't a little
bit more going on with her mother's character
like i was hoping for some secret identity or
just something a little bit cooler going on in
her past so it just felt a little weak the way
they ended her mother's arc in the episode then
the way they end ekko vs kingpin this scene here
is a reference to their ending in the comics
in the way she blinded him after learning the
truth about him killing her father obviously they
traded the daredevil character in this equation
for the hawkeye ronin character but if there's any
question even though you hear the gunshot kingpin
is still alive the other part of the comic book
reference here is when kingpin tells her sometimes
family doesn't see eye to eye well in the comics
when she shoots him when he appears next in the
daredevil comics he's blinded from the attack so
they're just trying to foreshadow that kingpin
will be coming back wounded during the echo
disney plus spin-off series we probably won't see
episodes for that till at least 2023 but the idea
is that when they come back for that like kingpin
will be a much bigger character he'll be unlike
all the episodes and charlie cox's matt murdock
and daredevil character will be back for that as
well for the echo episodes then hawkeye brings
kate bishop and pizza dog back to his farm to have
christmas with the family they finally confirmed
my mockingbird theory with his wife in the watch
so the watch belonged to hawkeye's wife laura but
on the back there's a shield logo and the number
19 that's a reference to agent 19 in the comics
aka mockingbird now they don't say it out loud but
the idea is that mockingbird's name is actually
barbara morse or bobby morse she was married to
hawkeye for a long time in the comics but in the
mcu we've only heard them call linda cartellini's
character laura so i think the idea is that her
middle name is laura and she just goes by that as
a way to keep her identity as mockingbird secret
like her real full name is probably bobby laura
morse barton i know a lot of you are asking
what does this mean about the mockingbird from
agents of shield played by adrian paliki i think
we can safely say based on this all that stuff
from agents of shield was happening in another
universe it's just the easiest way to explain that
just the easiest way to avoid any confusion with
mcu continuity like adrian paliki is a variant of
hawkeye's wife they burn hawkeye's ronin costume
which is actually something they probably should
have done before they left new york like i have
some questions about this why would hawkeye travel
with it when another villain could just attack him
and take it it just seems like an unnecessary
risk keeping it longer than he needed to
when kate bishop starts jokingly suggesting bad
code names for herself lady hawk hawk eve hawkshot
lady arrow all those joke names or references to
the funny names people called her and she tried to
call herself in the comics she's been called
hawkett hawkingbird kate hawk lady bro lady
hawkeye lady hawkman hawkiss tasmistress as a play
on taskmaster and weapon woman but the way they
played in the episode it's just set up for hawkeye
to have that scene at the end where he says you
know i have an idea and even though they cut to
black is obviously him saying why don't you just
call yourself hawkeye because in the comics kate
bishop also calls herself hawkeye like they both
exist at the same time there's like two different
characters that call themselves hawkeye during the
end credits they did have a special new christmas
card from marvel just saying happy holidays from
marvel studios in the actual post credits
scene no joke is legit just the full version
of the musical song save this city i was actually
pretty surprised by this like i kept watching
waiting for some kind of reveal like some
of the other avengers characters sitting in
the audience just kind of rolling their eyes and
laughing at the musical like can you believe this
so yeah i was a little disappointed at the post
credit scene i was hoping for something more on
par with the loki series where they're just like
teasing more plot like what's happening next with
these characters but the only other really big
question that i feel like they didn't answer
that they kind of should had was what did kingpin
want with mockingbird's shield watch like did it
have some secret information on it or was it
just a way to track down hawkeye's family as a
way to retaliate against hawkeye ronan because
of what he did during the five year time jump
and now we have so many questions about what
hawkeye's wife did during her time as mockingbird
when she was an active shield agent like where
are all those adventures like are there gonna
be flashbacks to that will she show up in some
other marvel disney plus series where they'll
tell that story but it was an awesome week
this week getting both daredevil and kingpin
back within a couple days of each other i'll
probably do some more daredevil and kingpin
videos this week i'm waiting a couple days to do
more spoilery videos on spider-man no way home
but if you spotted any other big easter eggs in
the episode that i didn't talk about during the
video or you have any other big questions about
what happened during the series just write it
below in the comments next week the mandalorian
book of boba fett star wars episodes are going
to be starting i'll be doing videos for all the
episodes just like i did for the mandalorian it's
kind of like the mandalorian season 2.5 with a
bunch of mandalorian characters crossing over
there's a lot of really cool stuff coming up
though we'll get some trailers for the other
marvel disney plus series pretty soon too while
you wait for that everyone click here for that
doctor strange 2 trailer video and click here for
my spider-man no way home post credits scene video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!